joining me now is person Charlie Kirk
president of Turning Point USA and
person Horace Cooper project 21 chairman
and author of put them put you all back
in Chains gentlemen uh I guess I
shouldn't say that people uh persons uh
thanks for joining us here tonight uh
Charlie help me here because there is
nothing worse I think than trying to go
woke the United States military
yeah it's the few the proud and the
genderless I suppose you know look I
deal with a lot of college campuses the
work we do at Turning Point USA and
something I've been warning for the last
couple years is what happens on college
campuses did not stay on college
campuses the woke mind virus will go
down as more dangerous long term than
the lab virus leak from the Wuhan
Institute of virology this infects every
major sector of society from Wall Street
financial institutions and now the
military it's easy to make fun of this
in fact I think mockery is very
cathartic and therapeutic because
there's nothing else we could do but
it's very dangerous this makes us less
prepared to fight enemies less prepared
to go against a CCP if now our military
is concerned with readjusting or
changing how they address drill sergeant
like how about you guys are worried
about I don't know protecting Taiwan
against the Chinese Communist Party
taking it over this is another example
of how wokism destroys everything it
touches
yeah Horace I heard Rob O'Neill he was
the guy who famously uh helped take out
uh uh Osama Bin Laden and he said you
know our military is over there trying
to figure out which bathrooms everybody
should use instead of trying to figure
out how to win win Wars and and that's
the problem I mean now you even have uh
religious institutions looking at trying
to and getting pressured to take and
change out Christmas carols for goodness
sake what is happening in this country
well I want to Echo uh Charlie's
comments about the danger involved here
we are in the middle of a recruitment
crisis we are having real challenges
maintaining the numbers of new entrants
to the military as well as getting
people to re-up and make a lifetime
career out of it the truth of the matter
is that service in the military is Noble
it's something that we should really
really strive to acknowledge and to
appreciate those people what the
wilsters are saying is that our military
is made up of people who are not modern
who are not competent who are not
capable I guess for some reason they
forget that even if you're in the
military first full-time
you still step off base and interact
with other human beings when you go on
leave you interact with other human
beings
why must the military which needs to
prioritize defending our country
maintaining our vigilance and telling
our leaders from the generals all the
way down to the Infantry that they need
to be ready for battle if battle
presents itself why must we waste time
instead of recognizing whatever societal
trends that there might be happening
they can still see them when they're on
their own time this is dangerous and
it's a waste of time
yeah let's make sure we can do enough
push-ups and get the people recruited in
there before they start doing uh you
know changing everybody's name and
whatnot and being so politically correct
Charlie another grievance I have is the
lionization of president zielinski have
a look at this
this was historic uh some people have
compared it to when Churchill came
zelinski is very much acting in the
churchillion tradition what could be a
churchillian moment most comparisons
have referenced another wartime leader
Winston Churchill
foreign your thoughts
yeah as a fond admire of Winston
Churchill I mean this is an insult to
anyone who studies history Winston
Churchill was the greatest figure of the
20th century my own personal uh very
charged feelings uh the Ukrainian War
aside I think we can all agree on in
fact 80 to 90 percent of Americans agree
that the fact that we are prioritizing
and standing ovation special uh Halls of
Congress ceremony for a foreign leader
while we are being invaded daily on our
Southern border is an insult to all of
us I would add that to your list of
Festivus airing of grievances that could
only be sorted to defeats of strength
hopefully our leaders will soon listen
to their voters and prioritize our
borders not that of a foreign country
Amen to that of course and uh Charlie uh
Merry Christmas thanks for joining us I
wish I had more time but I got to keep
going hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else